foreign
[Music]
the black dread as big or even bigger
than the dragons of Middle Earth well
this question is one to point her about
we do know that Valerian and Vega are
very big and the biggest to be seen in
the Game of Thrones universe but how do
we compare them as well as drogon with
the ones from tolkien's fantasy world
Middle Earth so let's get to it
let's start with the Targaryen dragon's
Origins there are quite a few origin
stories with the most common being that
the ancient people called the valerians
discovered their eggs in a volcanic
region called the 14 fires but there is
another theory that these fire breathing
monsters were hybrids of wyverns and
fireworms that were mixed together using
blood magic so these dragons have four
limbs with the front ones that have
developed into Wings they have
Serpentine body shape with a long neck
long tail and a bulbous torso they are
scaly they have horns rows of sharp
teeth and can breathe fire
now the origins of the Middle Earth
dragons these Dragons Were long-lived
powerful and cunning creatures
possessing high levels of intelligence
great physical strength and covered
nearly in impenetrable scales they were
bred by Margaret the original dark lord
and they were made by him because he
needed powerful soldiers to fight the
Angelic Valor the first one was glaurum
and was a fire breathing wingless
monstrosity then later he bred dragons
that had wings and were obliged to all
the free peoples of Middle Earth but
there were also dragons and Drakes that
could not breathe fire in that world
let's start with the size estimate for
Valerian there is no doubt the biggest
dragon from that world of Game of
Thrones was him he was brought to the
Western continent Westeros by a Valerian
called aegon Targaryen this dragon lived
to be over 200 years old and died of old
age but he never stopped growing till he
died his wingspan was so large that his
shadow could engulf entire towns when he
passed overhead his Jaws were large
enough to swallow an elephant hole so by
looking at the skull of this Behemoth
beneath the iron throne in the series we
can clearly see that it is over 10 feet
in height and that puts the skull alone
at around 20 to 25 feet long that would
put his overall length in the range of
330 to 400 feet long or 100 to 120
meters long
next the size estimate for Vega now we
are going to see Vega in the show House
of the dragon and by the time of the
dance of the Dragons she was a hardened
Survivor of a hundred battles and had
grown almost as large as valerion and
was the oldest and largest of the
dragons in Westeros at that point of
time her skull was found beneath the red
cape where the Iron Throne lies her
skull was huge the jaw could swallow an
entire horse easily and as we can see
the skull would have been eight to nine
feet in height so putting its length at
16 to 20 feet long just the skull
therefore with the same body proportion
similar to balerion she would have been
around 250 to 300 feet long around 75 to
90 meters
the size estimate for drogon now we come
to the most famous of the westerosi
dragons and the biggest living specimen
in the series Game of Thrones we have
already done a size estimate for drogon
and he would have had a skull length of
around 2 meters or more than 6 feet and
therefore have an overall body length of
close to 100 to 120 feet or 30 to 36
meters drogon grew at a very fast rate I
mean like Fast Forward into full kind of
deal in the first and second Seasons he
was the size of a house cat then by the
later Seasons we see him get an
overdrive in growth
now we come to Middle Earth the size
estimate for smoke the villain of The
Hobbit smart was the last real fire
Drake or Dragon although he was little
compared to his ancestors he was still
really Dreadful and responsible for the
death and Exile of the dwarves from
Erebor the Lonely Mountain Smoke is
described as being roughly 18 meters of
59 feet long and Karen winsteds the
atlas of Middle Earth although this is
more of an extreme underestimation smog
is described in other more reliable
accounts as being 130 meters of 427 feet
long which is longer than two Jumbo Jets
and more or less accurate if we look at
his appearance in Lake Town in the third
movie of the trilogy The Hobbit towering
over three to four storied houses that
were burning
now the size estimation for glaurum he
was the first fire breathing terrestrial
dragon and referred to as the father of
dragons Tolkien said that glauring was
quadrupedal he was a reptile without
wings and resembled a Chinese dragon or
sauropods he was a dreaded monster that
laid ways to an entire Elven Army so
even at his smallest estimate he would
have been at least bigger than smog for
this to happen given to the fact that a
man tier enslaved him with a sword trust
to his heart it would have been safe to
say that he wasn't that bigger than
smoke which was also killed by a Black
Arrow of the same size as a sword so
glaurum probably would be more than 150
meters of 500 feet since it was
described that his tail was very long
and lastly the size estimate for
ncalagon now we come to the biggest and
the most powerful Dragon that was bred
by margoth during the early ages of
Middle Earth he was as big as mountains
and as this excerpt from the
silmarillion explains before the rising
of the sun arindel slew and galagon the
black the Midas of the Dragon host and
cast him from the sky and he fell upon
the towers of tangoro dream and they
were broken in his rune
so these towers were volcanic mountains
and therefore that would put in caligon
at least in the kilometer or mile range
of size
so let's have a comparison and a
conclusion the smallest was drogon with
a size estimate of 30 to 36 meters of
100 to 120 feet long then Vega which is
75 to 90 meters or 250 to 300 feet long
then valerion at 100 to 120 meters or
330 to 40 feet then comes smoke from
Middle Earth which is estimated to be
over 130 meters or 427 feet around the
same size as Valerian and then comes
glarum which would be a little bigger
than both of them both smoke and
Valerian although being the only one
here without wings and then comes and
caligon the black lastly which is just a
black Titan which is in the kilometer
range in size
so that's it I hope you have enjoyed
watching this video do hit that like
button for support and subscribe but
most of all smash that Bell icon for
regular updates on new videos right here
on this channel till the next one take
care fam